según el presidente joe biden en la
situación podría llegar al límite
rápidamente por lo que instó a los
ciudadanos estadounidenses a abandonar
ucrania inmediatamente en una entrevista
con en vice news el jueves mira lo que
pedido es que los ciudadanos
estadounidenses se vayan que se vayan
ahora estamos tratando con uno de los
mayores ejércitos del mundo es una
situación muy diferente el mandatario
aseguró que no enviaría tropas a rusia
ya que eso desencadenaría una guerra
mundial el duro mensaje de vaivén se
produjo junto a la afirmación del primer
ministro de reino unido de que europa se
enfrenta a su mayor crisis de seguridad
en décadas mientras tanto en belarús
rusia ya comenzó diez días de ejercicios
militares conjuntos pero el bando
ucraniano también inició maniobras
militares cerca de la frontera con
belarús y en el donbass en este contexto
los esfuerzos diplomáticos para frenar
la crisis continúan en el marco del
formato de normandía los representantes
de rusia ucrania alemania y francia- no
lograron llegar a un acuerdo sobre el
donbass sumido en un conflicto de 8 años
moscú quiere que los territorios
separatistas del donbass tengan
autonomía pero ucrania quieren
mantenerlos tras la anexión de crimea en
y aquí no hemos podido ponernos de
acuerdo en la firma de un documento de
hecho las conversaciones de hoy han
durado casi nueve horas espero que nos
reunamos de nuevo muy pronto y
continuemos estas conversaciones por sus
trinos
siempre móviles oficialmente ambos
países quieren un alto el fuego pero con
más de 100.000 soldados acumulados en la
frontera de ucrania las tensiones siguen
siendo altas mientras rusia niega
repetidamente sus planes de invasión